Transcription: Zuzana Prochazkova
Relecteur: eric vautier
Il y a un peu plus de 20 ans, ma compagne
et moi, on avait un rêve,
une vieille maison à la campagne
avec des fruitiers, un puits,
des oiseaux dans les arbres, une cheminée
et une belle vue sur la campagne.
Et puis, le rêve est devenu réalité,
on a acheté une vieille
ferme en Bourgogne.
Il y avait des fruitiers,
des oiseaux dans les arbres,
un puits, une cheminée,
une belle vue sur la campagne.
On a fait notre potager,
on retournait les pierres,
et sous les pierres,
il y avait des crapauds.
En journée, on écoutait
le chant des oiseaux
et le soir, c’était concert des grillons.
Et puis,
les crapauds ont disparu,
les insectes se sont escamotés,
On n’a plus entendu les oiseaux, finies
les mésanges, adieu les chardonnerets...
En journée, c'était silence et le soir,
c'était aussi silence.
Cette douloureuse disparition du vivant
autour de moi,
je ne suis pas le seul à l’avoir vécu,
bien évidemment,
Il y a même des mots pour ça :
solastalgie, écoanxiété...
Mon remède à moi en tant
que journaliste scientifique,
ça a été d’écrire un livre :
« Cataclysmes, une histoire
environnementale de l’humanité ».
Je suis remonté jusqu’aux origines
et j’ai essayé de documenter les rapports
entre l’humanité et son milieu.
Rétrospectivement, je pense
que c’était une manière
de mettre des mots sur ce que je vivais.
De leur côté, des scientifiques
ont posé un concept :
anthropocène, l’ère de l’humanité.
C’est un mot savant pour dire
que nous vivons désormais
sur une planète qui va se réchauffant,
dans un monde où la biodiversité s’érode,
dans un monde où le vivant cède
progressivement la place
à nos matériaux inertes :
le béton, le plastique, le goudron.
Je pense que c’est le plus angoissant
des sauts dans l’inconnu
que l’on puisse concevoir,
à savoir une terre impactée en profondeur
par nos activités,
au point de remettre en question
jusqu’aux fondements
mêmes de notre existence.
Mais le dire ne suffit pas, car nous
sommes en train de le vivre.
Nous allons devoir vivre en anthropocène
et cela implique d’apprivoiser ce monstre
anthropocène si nous voulons lui survivre,
et c’est là un programme politique.
Alors bien sûr, me direz-vous,
le politique aujourd’hui,
c’est l’impuissance.
L’impuissance face
au dérèglement climatique,
l’impuissance face
à l’effondrement du vivant,
l’impuissance face à l’extension
du domaine des pollutions.
Et pourtant, il est possible
d’aller au-delà.
Mais d’abord,
pourquoi restons-nous inertes ?
D’abord parce qu’il y a peu de gens
qui se saisissent réellement
de l’ampleur du problème.
Ceux qui essayent de s’investir dans
ce domaine sont trop peu nombreux
et ils font face
à deux polarités opposées.
Je vais prendre l'image d'une rivière.
Imaginez l’anthropocène comme
un flot de mauvaises nouvelles,
un torrent absolument [inarrêtable].
Vous pouvez essayer de rester au milieu
du torrent, de nager dans ce chaos,
tout en vous stabilisant, en imaginant
que vous pouvez trouver
quelque chose à quoi vous raccrocher.
Un potager en permaculture,
un groupe de parole,
mais vous êtes tenté de rejoindre
une des rives.
Et il y a deux rives - enfin,
en tout cas, j’en vois deux -
il y a la rive des technophiles,
ceux qui agitent la main en disant :
« Mais la technologie va nous sauver.
L’Humanité s’en est toujours sortie,
elle s’en sortira encore. »
Et puis il y a la rive des mystiques,
ceux qui pensent que la spiritualité
nous permettra de traverser le pire.
Pour ma part, j’ai plutôt envie de revenir
aux sources du torrent,
d’opérer un retour sur l’histoire
et d’écouter d’où pourrait
venir cet anthropocène.
Il y a deux grandes hypothèses.
La première dit : l’anthropocène remonte
à la révolution industrielle,
notamment en Angleterre,
où des ingénieurs mettent au point,
perfectionnent des moteurs à combustion
basés sur le charbon.
Des capitalistes investissent.
Ils ramènent ces moteurs puissants
dans des filatures.
Les ateliers se transforment en usines,
les artisans deviennent des prolétaires.
Tout cela dégage des profits.
Une petite partie des profits
ruissellera sur les prolétaires
qui formeront  une classe moyenne.
La plus grande partie des profits
ira dans les poches des élites.
Ce pourquoi certains veulent
parler de capitalocène
puisqu’il a fallu pour que
cette histoire se construise
qu’il y ait des capitaux qui circulent,
des capitaux basés
sur l’extraction du charbon,
mais aussi sur les trafics d’esclaves,
sur l’expropriation des
communautés paysannes.
Mais fondamentalement, ce que cela
nous dit de notre monde d’aujourd’hui,
ce terme de capitalocène,
c’est que l’anthropocène
est une histoire d’inégalité
parce qu’encore aujourd’hui,
les plus riches émettent beaucoup plus de
gaz à effet de serre que les plus pauvres.
Il y a une autre version,
on peut la faire remonter
à l’après Seconde Guerre mondiale.
C’est certes le moment
où les premières bombes atomiques
laissent une trace sur la planète
sous forme de radiations perceptibles
partout sur la planète.
Mais c’est aussi le moment
où s’impose une révolution verte
à travers le plan Marshall, l’argent
que les Américains remettent à l’Europe.
Cette révolution verte consiste en fait
à faire main basse sur le vivant
de la part de grandes firmes
qui vont produire
des grains sélectionnés,
hybrides, donc stériles,
modifiés, par exemple pour avoir
plus de gluten dans le blé
et nécessitant de grands
investissements pour être déployés,
ainsi qu’une forte mécanisation.
Cela implique des monocultures.
Les monocultures sont
plus fragiles aux maladies ?
Qu’importe, on balance dessus la chimie
héritée des deux guerres mondiales,
des pesticides,
des herbicides,
des fongicides, des meurtriers.
Et tout ça détruit la fertilité du sol en
tuant les vers et les micro-organismes ?
Qu’importe, on a une solution,
le procédé Haber Bosch,
développé pour fabriquer des explosifs.
On utilise du gaz naturel pour extraire
l'azote de l'air et faire des nitrates.
Tous ces procédés génèrent
énormément de pollution,
non seulement du dioxyde de carbone,
de l’ammoniac, du méthane.
Ce sont donc des pollutions
qui affectent le climat,
comme le sol, l’eau ou les océans.
C’est pour ça que le vivant recule.
Il recule d’autant plus vite que
ces procédés-là, cette histoire-là
se reproduit en urbanisme, se reproduit
également en industrie,
les paysans désertent la campagne,
les villes deviennent tentaculaires,
la voiture se substitue
aux transports en commun.
Quant au bétail, il se retrouve parqué
et abattu dans des
conditions concentrationnaires.
On peut alors parler de Thanatocène,
l’ère de la mort
pour signifier que l’humanité
est en guerre contre le vivant,
à l’insu de notre plein gré évidemment.
La nature s’effondre donc, certes
parce que nous sommes plus nombreux,
mais ne nous trompons pas de combat,
la nature s’effondre surtout
parce que nous la fractionnons
avec nos infrastructures
parce que nous artificialisons la terre,
parce que nous la polluons
avec notre chimie
et surtout notre développement,
obsessionnellement articulé
sur la croissance de l’idole PIB -
produit intérieur brut.
Nous pouvons vivre autrement,
à 10 milliards sur Terre,
sans dépasser les limites planétaires,
avec de l’agroécologie, avec un urbanisme
repensé à l’échelle humaine
et de la solidarité internationale.
Notre situation résulte
de choix antérieurs
qui ont été imposés aux sociétés.
Je vais prendre l’exemple du magnat
de l’automobile Henry Ford,
qui a racheté les compagnies de bus
et les a laissés péricliter
afin d’imposer sa solution à lui,
qui était des voitures
construites en atelier
sur des chaînes de montage.
Tout en expliquant aux salariés
qu’il accroissait leur productivité
et donc leur salaire, alors que
c’est dans la poche d’Henry Ford
et dans celle des actionnaires
que terminaient les profits.
Des philanthropes
avec les mêmes arguments,
ont imposé la révolution verte,
par exemple à l’Inde.
Aujourd’hui, les paysans indiens
se suicident
parce qu’ils n’ont plus les moyens
d’acheter les semences stériles,
les engrais et les pesticides
qui vont avec.
Alors que leurs parents nourrissaient
l’Asie avec leur savoir-faire, leur riz,
leurs méthodes de désherbage
et leurs techniques de fertilisation
à base de collecte des effluents.
Je ne raconte pas cela
pour me lamenter sur le passé,
car nous vivons mieux aujourd’hui
que nous ne l’avons jamais fait
de toute l’histoire de l’humanité.
Je veux dire par là que nous vivons
plus vieux, en meilleure santé,
avec un accès à beaucoup plus
de biens et d’informations
que ce que nous pouvions imaginer
il y a même trente ans.
Mais le Covid-19 nous
lance un avertissement :
à trop exiger de la nature,
à la solliciter au-delà du raisonnable
pour soutenir une économie
toujours plus gourmande en ressources,
nous risquons fort
d’en payer un prix extrême.
D’ores et déjà, les sécheresses, les
méga-feux, les inondations, les cyclones,
les pollutions de l’air et de l’eau
impactent fortement des populations
de plus en plus vulnérables
et menacent l’équilibre
économique mondial.
Un jour, l’économie hoquètera, étouffera,
et nous nous retrouverons alors
dans un tourbillon de décisions
politiques absurdes.
Nous avons d’ores et déjà oublié
ce qui fait la valeur d’une vie humaine.
L’Europe nous parle de démocratie
et criminalise ceux qui tentent
de porter secours aux migrants.
Notre gouvernement exalte l’écologie
et démantèle pourtant le peu
de structures et de règlements
qui permettraient
de protéger la biodiversité.
Et tout ceci relève du politique.
Je voudrais citer Max Weber, sociologue
qui, au début du 20ème siècle, écrivait :
« Chacun trouve aujourd’hui en naissant
l’économie capitaliste
établie comme un immense cosmos,
un habitacle dans lequel il doit vivre
et ne peut rien changer,
du moins en tant qu’individu. »
Ce que nous disait déjà Max Weber,
c’est que pour faire changer les choses,
il faut agir collectivement
et donc au niveau politique.
Cela ne disqualifie pas ceux qui se
préparent dans leur vie aux difficultés,
ceux qui créent
des archipels de résistance,
car leur expérience sera utile
pour mobiliser, créer des précédents,
pousser à l’action.
Mais cela ne suffira pas à atteindre
l’objectif primordial qui est :
faire en sorte qu’à l’horizon 2050,
quand il y aura 10 milliards
d’humains sur Terre,
le plus possible de ces humains
puissent vivre une vie digne.
Et cela, dans le respect
des limites planétaires.
Pour vivre en anthropocène dignement,
il faut une feuille de route.
Cela exige de prendre le temps
d’étudier la totalité de l’anthropocène
pour mieux cibler
les meilleures façons d’agir.
Certains veulent tuer
la notion d’anthropocène.
Ils prétendent que ce serait
une lubie de savants fous
qui voudraient prendre le contrôle
du système Terre avec de la géoingénierie.
Cette idée serait si dangereuse qu’elle
ne mériterait même pas d’être discutée.
Pourtant, l’anthropocène est
un fait géologiquement constatable.
L’ensemble de l’humanité est en train
de modifier en profondeur
les paramètres du système Terre.
Le tout dans un tourbillon
d'inégalités croissantes.
Et que nous soyons, nous humains,
devenus la principale force
géologique à l’œuvre sur Terre,
nous met face à nos responsabilités.
Nous perturbons ou détruisons le vivant,
comme les ressources en eau,
la stabilité climatique, comme
les sols qui nous nourrissent.
C'est un fait.
Et c'est lié à l'économie de croissance.
On peut la repeindre en vert ou en bleu,
cela n'y changera rien.
Il nous faut changer radicalement
de comportement
et il faut prendre l’anthropocène
pour ce qu’il est,
à savoir une enveloppe,
une enveloppe dans laquelle
l’humanité peut mettre en commun
ses attentes, ses espoirs,
ses craintes et ses récits.
Et c’est une enveloppe dans laquelle
nous allons puiser nos connaissances
pour nous battre.
On peut prendre par exemple
dans cette enveloppe la carte
« Agriculture du futur ».
Ça peut être une agriculture
à base d’agroécologie,
où l’on sortira progressivement
des intrants chimiques
et où on sortira également le bétail
des conditions concentrationnaires
dans lesquelles il se trouve.
Il y a une autre carte
« Agriculture du futur » dedans,
c’est celle de l’économie
comme elle existe aujourd'hui.
Et celle-ci sera à base d’OGM.
Ce sera une agriculture sans paysans,
où les robots feront le travail
des paysans ou des abeilles
et où les pesticides seront toujours
plus volumineux et plus toxiques.
Aujourd’hui, en Occident,
nous vivons dans un confort
que personne avant nous
dans l’histoire n’a jamais connu.
Et c’est pour ça que nous restons inertes.
Personne n’a envie de renoncer
à ce confort pour entrer en lutte.
Ce que nous dit l’anthropocène,
c’est que pourtant, nous devons renoncer
à certains des éléments
qui font ce confort.
Il faudra à l’avenir
manger moins de viande,
travailler moins, faire preuve
de plus de solidarité,
s’efforcer de brider les firmes
dans leur accès aux ressources
afin de mieux les répartir.
Il faudra se mesurer à l’anthropocène
pour faire en sorte qu’à l’horizon 2050,
le plus possible de gens puissent
vivre dignement.
Seule une mobilisation citoyenne
nous permettra d’obliger les États
à prendre en compte non pas
leurs seuls intérêts égoïstes,
mais les intérêts
de l’ensemble de l’Humanité.
Et ce n’est pas un choix,
c’est une nécessité morale.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)